Lionel Messi says he can't do it anymore,...
...after a devastating loss on the Copa America final,...
...the Argentina forward announcing he will retire from playing international soccer.
Argentina lost to Chile 4-2 in the title game on Sunday,...
...during which Messi missed a penalty kick.
After the game, the 29-year-old striker expressed his frustration...
...in having missed out on the trophy again.
Argentina failed to grab the victory in the 2014 World Cup Final,...
...and then again in the 2015 Copa America to Chile.
Messi who currently plays for Barcelona in the Spanish soccer league...
...is Argentina's leading goal scorer with 55 goals.
The bottom line? Third time, not a charm for Lionel Messi.